you live in austin and uh what kind of
stuff do you do uh how does how do you
plot what is your trade how do you make
your living how do you get the dough my
day job i am a director of purchasing
for a large commercial design firm that
specializes in senior living and
multi-family community okay but my side
hustle is a different story all right
let's talk about your side hustle that
would be a dungeon master conan okay
a dungeons and dragons dungeon master
correct not a sex thing let's be
perfectly clear i'm pretty sure that
they cleared that up oh yeah oh well i
just lost all my enthusiasm for this
instantly i know i just i
apologize i swear to god
i totally
i'm completely i'm just gonna hang up on
you now
no uh yeah i'm gonna be honest with you
i've never played dungeons and dragons
and i know nothing about it and i know
it's a huge thing and people take it
very seriously and so i want you to
educate me about this dungeons and
dragons world you are the dungeon master
which means you run the games is that
right correct i am effectively the
referee and host for a group of players
who come together and to experience a
collaborative storytelling experience
the dungeon master is the writer
director producer and every single
background character ah so you're
sexually harassing everyone
[Laughter]
wait so i'm also the hr department so
who are they going to there you go yeah
it's the best scam of all uh you know
it's interesting because um i happen to
know people take this very seriously and
i've heard through friends
that uh the actor joe manganiello is i
can speak to that personally yeah oh
okay well you tell us because i've heard
he's incredibly ta he takes this very
seriously so seriously that i think i
made one too many jokes and wasn't asked
back oh no right and i don't want to
tell tales out of school but he has a
converted wine cellar that is now a
dungeon in his home filled with
thousands of d d figurines like army's
masks i love how you're not telling
tales at a school you just completely
didn't do it you just completely sold
out joe manconello who's a lovely guy by
the way i've met him
he's a lovely guy and he's really funny
he's got a great sense of humor but he
takes dungeons and dragons really
seriously and i can imagine matt you
being there making your quips as you do
and trust me i've been on the verge of
uh kicking you out out of this
enterprise many times yeah because
you're just quipping away and
chuckling over there in the corner so
people do take it quite seriously and
there's a lot of work that goes into
uh having an effective game is is that
correct turner coats the third
absolutely you've if if you're if just
to build a
world that you can immerse players in
you spend a lot of time doing research
and and players like poking funds at the
fund at the boundary of that research
they're very you know they love to ask
for non-player character names on the
spot to see if you've named every third
towns townsperson that you've you've put
into this small village this reminds me
of uh it's very similar too if you ever
go to like old sturbridge village which
is about 40 miles from where i grew up
in massachusetts it's one of those
communities where
everyone dresses like a pilgrim pretty
much and they live in a little pilgrim
village when we were in grade school
they would take us there and i would
walk around with my classmates and you'd
go in
basically the illusion is that you're
supposed to be time traveling so there'd
be a smithy in there and he'd be
hammering away at the shoes of the for a
horseshoe
and saying ah
these young
you know folk have come you know privy
uh have a seat and we were [ __ ] we'd
be like hey what do you think this is
and show them our shitty digital
1980 digital watch what do you think
this is and you could see the guys just
eyes glaze over and he'd he'd go oh
prithee
gadzook's tis witchcraft
upon ye risk this magical and
you know i just like these crappy kids
coming in and that's essentially what
sometimes i'm guessing people were
trying to do in a dungeons and dragons
game and why matt gurley was kicked out
well you know
it's very important that whenever you go
into a a new group situation that you
make sure that you're playing the same
game dnd can be deadly serious you can
really get into the shakespearean henry
v depths with it
that's not what i tend to play i go a
lot sillier with it because that's kind
of what i enjoy you know we do give the
authority as dungeon master to banish
someone absolutely have you banished
people
i've asked people not to come back to
the table yes i okay i absolutely have
just because i give you the authority
during our conversation to banish matt
gourley if you find his quips to be too
inane i accept this boon the turner i do
not give you that a thought
when we send it
not noted
thank you